Russia has said it now controls 97
percent of luhansk one of the two
Ukrainian provinces that make up the
donbass the Kremlin has made taking the
Eastern region its number one objective
in this phase of the war and has been
bombarding the city of Savannah Donetsk
and surrounding areas Ukraine's
president of Vladimir zielinski says his
forces are putting up a fierce defense
and inflicting a heavy toll on Russia's
military
[Music]
smoke and destruction across severo
donesque
the fight for the key industrial Hub has
emerged as a pivotal battle in the war
Russia has claimed to have taken full
control of all the residential
neighborhoods there
but Ukrainian officials say it's
outnumbered troops are fighting on
Ukraine's President zielinski says the
Russian Advance has come at the cost of
thousands of its troops
is 31
000 Russian servicemen have already died
in Ukraine since February 24th Russia
has been paying almost 300 lives a day
for completely pointless war against
Ukraine so they will come when the
number of losses can no longer be
tolerated even for Russia
but what do they stand to gain from this
most of the occupying forces have
already understood that they have no
prospects in Ukraine we can see this
reflected in conversations we've
intercepted this is the mood permeating
the Russian army we are free people
we're not your slaves
about 65 kilometers West the city of
slovians has been hit by heavy shelling
as Russian forces continue to advance
further in the donbass region
but many residents are refusing to leave
I'm going to stay here
I will not leave without my husband
[Music]
he works here
so we've decided to stay
it's tough but it's easier when one is
at home
we're going to stay now because it's too
dangerous to move they're shooting
everywhere but we hope all will be well
essential Aid
while Clinging On to hopes of survival
Natalia Pippa is a member of an
opposition party in the Ukrainian
Parliament she has just wrapped up a
trip through Germany and Switzerland a
very warm welcome to DW news Miss Pippa
you met with policymakers I understand
in both countries Switzerland and
Germany did they give you assurances
that Ukraine will keep getting the
support it's asking for
yes on the like a level of cities like
Freiburg on level a city like Barn yes
we have to communicate and I know that
55 in Germany are a support Ukraine and
speak for me a lot please tell to
Ukrainian people the Germans support
Ukraine and we are shaming on our
governance especially Schultz and we
understand Khan this person speaks there
we don't give can uh can't give weapon
to Ukraine because we don't know how to
provide in which cancer something like
this the a lot of people from Germany
are really understand values of
democracy peace and humanity and we
really feel it in Freiburg especially
and when a lot speak with us what we can
help Ukraine like we like German must
give money for medicine
school books and something like this I I
have written this in my Facebook but I
can
I speak to that you can write letter to
Sean so you can make patties to shorts
and government must wear
um open Society it is really helpful we
speak together about the weapon we need
just for protect and a lot of German
people understand it and we speak about
Ukraine like candidates and a lot of
Germans people said yes we see them diet
Force yes Miss Peppa I we have a very
limited time and I I want to have a
conversation with you um the Russian
foreign minister as you know is in
Turkey right now to discuss ways to get
grain out of Ukrainian ports which
according to the UN is causing a global
food crisis Moscow says in order for
that to happen Ukraine must demign its
Harbors to allow ships to leave what
would your answer be to that
we speak about it for uh we must to
remember Russia the blocked Ukrainian
force is this all uh a lot tons of food
Russia it is it happens for four months
Ukraine all time is uh open to speak and
provide this food and the best way is
just Russia must go out to to over the
port and stay there at normally uh we
can make provide this old food I will
speak about when accident was
International ship was in this area
where is Russian ship and go to control
this International ship and it was take
10 or 20 hours and every person in this
shift must take off clothes that's all
and this Rush control for us all tattoos
and other it is like controlled by
Russia for other International ship it's
really big problem in the best way is
Russia must go out to his oven to oven
water and Ukraine is interested to
provide this food because it is like not
for famine in the world and it is about
export from Ukraine too that is very
important for all ukrainians Natalia
pepper Ukrainian Member of Parliament
thank you so much for joining us
thank you
and I want to reach out now to DW
correspondent Nick Conley he is in
Odessa Nick things are not looking good
for severe dunesque
well definitely that Russian offensive
continues Russia has basically a
step-by-step reduced its War aims from
trying to basically take the whole
country at the beginning of this war in
late February early March to focusing on
the south and the east then basically
seemingly it's given up trying to go for
kharkiv Ukraine's second Big City close
to the Russian border it's also
withdrawing the South near her son and
now it's basically thrown everything it
has a very very very short uh compact
stretch of the front lines
maximum Firepower maximum Manpower and
still it's not really making huge leaps
but it is step by step day for day
taking more territory and outgunning the
ukrainians who for now are still in the
city against all the expectations of
observers who thought it was a matter of
days this is happening on for weeks a
bit similar to maripole but it looks
like the ukrainians if this carries on
will at some point have to cut their
losses and withdraw from the city to
avoid
disproportionate losses in terms of
their soldiers now Nick Russia
state-owned news agency is reporting
that more than a thousand of the
Ukrainian soldiers who surrendered at
those steel Works in mayuple are being
transported to Russia for quote unquote
investigation what more have you been
able to learn about that
well this was something that was feared
in Ukraine all along initially when
maripol uh basically was taken by the
Russians and that steel Works after
weeks of resistance allowed the Russians
in there was hope that there would be a
quick exchange of prisoners lots of
Russian prisoners of War here in Ukraine
but that hasn't happened for lots of
reasons I think it's mainly about the
propagandistic Battle Russia obviously
isn't doing well internationally in
terms of the international perception of
this it's doing a bit better in African
Asia than it is in Europe and North
America certainly but still not getting
the kind of international diplomatic
support that it might have hoped for so
now I'm trying to build a case to try
and show these Ukrainian service people
and volunteer military units as being
right-wing radicals as part of that
narrative that Russia advance in the
lead up to this war of Ukraine as a
hotbed of near Nazism so people here in
Ukraine definitely expecting show trials
and a long long wait for any of those
people to get back to their families
here in Ukraine and Nick as we started
this broadcast we were talking about the
talks that are underway in Turkey to try
and get grain out of uh Ukrainian ports
now for that to happen Ukraine would
have to demign its harbors and Russia
would essentially have to commit to not
attacking a Ukraine do you see any
chance of that happening
look I'm not even allowed to be near the
port here in Odessa to do this live from
the place we were all talking about
because the worries here about the
security of that port and of Russia
finding out any minimal details are so
big that we're kept away from there so
the idea that Ukraine given all the bad
blood and given the total lack of trust
over any kind of temporary deals with
Russia would take those mines away and
open Odessa which is a prime target for
Russia's Advance open that up to attack
I think is pretty optimistic especially
given that the Turkish attempt at
mediation basically they've said that
they would accompany private grain
vessels along part of the route but
there's no mechanism if Russia doesn't
stick to its side of the deal that the
Turkish navy ships for instance would
protect Ukraine's coasts I think right
now this is about the blame game and
Russia has discovered that this is going
down very badly in the Middle East and
North Africa where that Ukrainian grain
normally goes and they're trying to put
the blame for those Rising grain prices
on the ukrainians and not much more than
that
DW correspondent Nick Connelly reporting
from Odessa Ukraine thank you Nick
Fox and Istanbul between Russia and
turkey's top diplomats on how to get
grain out of Ukraine have not yielded a
breakthrough Ukraine was not represented
in Russian foreign minister Sergey
lavrov said Moscow was ready to ensure
safety of ships leaving Ukrainian ports
but Ukraine says it will not remove
mines from Waters around Odessa citing
the threat of Russian attacks tens of
millions of tons of wheat corn and
sunflower oil are trapped after Russia
blockaded Ukraine's Coastline three
months ago both sides blame each other
for laying sea mines off the Black Sea
Coast
well speaking at a press conference in
Ankara Turkish for a minute turkey's
foreign minister stress the urgent need
to resolve the stalemate take a listen
I'd like to say that the global food
crisis is a real crisis we should not
look at it as only exporting Ukrainian
grain products
we should look at it as exporting both
Ukrainian and Russian grain products and
fertilizer
our DW correspondent Dorian Jones in
Istanbul follows this meeting and had
this update on possible outcomes of the
talks
well it does appear that there are still
major issues to be resolved before any
uh grain Corridor allowing Ukrainian
ships onto the world markets can succeed
uh the Turkish foreign minister Maverick
did say that they were working on the
technicalities of how that would proceed
Turkish vessels would be involved in
checking any Ukrainian ships entering
Ukrainian Imports weren't carrying
weapons to an acknowledgment of Russian
concerns but the coverage order did
admit that they have still a long way to
go to secure trust between the two sides
to achieve this Corridor of green for
the world markets and now we understand
Dorian that turkey has offered to help
facilitate getting grain out of
Ukrainian ports how are they planning on
going about doing that
foreign
Turkish and Russian naval ships would
work on this Corridor that would allow
ships to enter the Black Sea ports of
the Ukraine and then we'll safely would
depart to the world markets now turkey
would also participate in what is
considered the most tricky part the
demining of particularly the Ukrainian
ports to allow safe access to these
ships but the problem here is that
basically Ukraine wants guarantees that
Russia will not take advantage of this
demining to a launch an amphibious
attacker particularly on the critical
Port of Odessa and uh Sergey lavross the
Russian foreign minister said that we
would promise not to take advantage but
this offer was dismissed immediately by
the Ukrainian foreign minister calling
it empty words now how to resolve this
current impasse and it's all about trust
until that's bridge then it isn't
expected to be any progress on on this
deal are there any plans to speak to
Ukraine's leaders
well uh Turkish foreign did try to
strike a bit of optimism saying that it
did appear that Ukraine was ready for
talks that they said that things had
improved toki's very keen to position
itself as a facilitator but Russian
foreign minister lavarov appear to
dismiss this saying that any such talks
would be merely symbolic so I don't
think there's any expectation of any
major meeting anytime soon
and in conclusion Dorian we understand
that Mr lavrov traveled with a military
delegation to Turkey
that's right this is all about Turkish
requests from Russia to allow to launch
a major operation into Syria in
russian-controlled territory against
Syrian Kurdish Fighters which Ankara
demons terrorists but Russia seems still
very cool on that uh Sergey lavrov said
that yes we understand Turkish concerns
but we will we want to talk about this
next month for the meeting in Astana
where it's a regular meeting between
Iran turkey and Russia so it doesn't
appear that turkey is close to any green
light for any operation in anytime soon
to Dorian Jones that reporting from
Istanbul Turkey thank you